[Music]
do you think it's another puzzle or
whatever it is you better figure it out
for us we're trying to buy us some time
hey can i get you a drink
this definitely isn't gin and tonic but
it is on the house
yes
okay whoa whoa whoa let me go pina
colada
[Music]
i think you're a comedian
okay i got it i got it six on the beach
i've been dreaming about this in my life
magellan's gold it's the biggest
treasure that's never been found five
billion easy
so when do we start yeah put that in
your head
hello hello
i can hear you i'm sitting right next to
you
your brother believed that there was a
final piece
oh you know my brother sam what else
aren't you telling me
you have no idea who you partnered with
silly
it's gonna take a little longer than i
thought yet
i assume we're 50 50 right
50 50. you get 10 that's me being
generous wow
let's play some parachutes what
unless a little better way to jump out
of the play
oh my god i'm so sorry
come on
500 years ago my family found the
vulture
and was betrayed
so much blood
this ain't over
hey you still with me
barely
what's with the cat she's just real what
life seems super sad i'm not gonna keep
this thing exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
you